to Las Vegas now Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment shares four things you can
do if you have an accident at work
hi I'm attorney Eric Palacios welcome to
the legal minute today we're going to
answer the question what four things you
should do if you suffer an accident at
work number one inform a supervisor it's
important to immediately tell your
supervisor you had an accident and to
make a list of any co-workers who saw
the accident even if you don't believe
you're hurt let your supervisor know
number two seek medical attention as
soon as possible if you have pain don't
wait days or even weeks to see if you
get better on your own ask to see a
medical provider the sooner the better
number three let the doctor and medical
staff know it was a work injury ask the
staff to fill out the required medical
form this form is called a C4
finally four seek the advice of an
experienced workers comp attorney
immediately if you don't request certain
benefits right away you may lose your
rights or benefits permanently this has
been the legal minute we'll see you next
time
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com